en tant qu'acteur, je fais semblant de gagner ma vie Je
joue des personnages fictifs qui résolvent souvent des
problèmes fictifs
Je crois que l'humanité a envisagé le
changement climatique de la même manière que s'il
s'agissait d'une fiction
[Musique] des
milliers de climatologues s'accordent sur le fait
que le réchauffement climatique n'est pas seulement le
problème environnemental le plus menaçant mais
l'un des plus grands défis auxquels est confrontée
toute l'humanité
[Musique] l'
air pur et un climat vivable sont dans
une étiquette Droits de l'Homme et résoudre cette
crise n'est pas une question de politique c'est
une question de notre propre survie
[Musique]
les défis qui nous attendent exigent que chacun
d'entre nous agisse, nous le
devons à nous-mêmes, mais plus
important encore, nous le devons aux
générations futures qui comptent sur nous tous.
[Musique] le
changement climatique est réel, il se produit
en ce moment, c'est le moment  menace la plus urgente
qui pèse sur toute notre espèce
[Musique]
Je ne peux pas imaginer avoir un
leader politique qui n'écoute pas la
communauté scientifique
[Musique]
nous ne devrions pas avoir de gens au pouvoir qui
ne croient pas aux faits et rétorquent les
vérités  la science moderne qui est capable
de manipuler et de risquer tout l'avenir
de toute cette génération
[Musique]
vous